[Music]
hello this is national master Joanne
palenko from the state of Missouri and
today we will continue with part two of
part two in our series which will never
be continued again so this is part three
basically on the caro-kann structures
involving d5 and c6 against basically
everything now I noticed there was a
comment in the last video that said that
I forgot to cover the accelerator pan
off and that's sure so I will do that
right now
the accelerator pan off starts with E
for c6 and the move pawn to c4 the
differences between this this version of
the pan off and the previous one where
white plays d4 and tries to take on d5
is white is banking on having extra
development where maybe he won't move
his D pawn immediately and just develop
his minor pieces so for example if black
plays d5 which I would recommend white
can take twice and if black were to take
back with this Queen
for example then white would gain a lot
of time and development with a move like
Knight c3 and then Knight f3 and white
has two pieces out to Black's none and
this is an open position so white would
have a fairly substantial advantage so
what most people do here is they play
the move Knight to f6 because they don't
want to take back on d5 with the Queen
as it will be hid obviously and ideally
they would like to establish the knight
on d5 and from White's perspective if he
can avoid playing the move pawn to d4
then he can claim he has some kind of
improved panel so 9 to f6 Knight to c3
less I should mention that we we
shouldn't try to transpose to any pan
off lines here because it's going to be
very difficult in in our lines to to get
to a position where we can play the move
Bishop to e6 which is the thing that I
recommend you should do
I think Bishop e6 is the best move in
this position if you're trying to play
for a win and that is not going to be
possible after the move pawn to c4 so we
may as well just forget about all the
transpositions Knight to f6 Knight to c3
if Bishop to b5 check the best movement
is Knight B to d7 Knight C 3 a six if
Queen to a4 so the point the point of
Bishop to b5 is obviously we want to
block the Queen from from looking at the
d5 pawn so now if Y protects it with a
piece it's only it's only intact once so
ninety seven the Queen can't see d5
anymore Knight c3 d5 is protected a six
and Queen a four with the obvious idea
that you can't take on b5 because Queen
takes a a would win the game so rook to
b8 and here White has to make a decision
if he if you were to go backwards with
this Bishop somewhere like e 2 or C 4
obviously is extremely bad I'll ask the
audience black to play what would you do
here with black yeah I think it's a
little weird right because from our
perspective the bishop was placed on b5
to pin the night right and then it moves
away so we think that it's not pin but
it's still pinned because the queen is 4
but yeah there is a fork here can
anybody find the fork I know you know at
home God these people with engines turn
on their engine and they yell in the
comments too easy
yeah be fine it's simple yeah just a
simple pawn fork and white loses
material so why would have to go back
somewhere else and then black would play
b5 and if white goes away let's say to
d1 I don't think it really matters what
would you do here with black to obtain a
very decent position so what we want to
do is we want to regain our pawn right
all we the only thing you need to do to
do that is to attack it a a attack at
once right so the move Knight to b6 is
actually very good for black black gets
a very decent version of standard pen
off position or not pan off but isolated
queen pawn positions
he already has space on the Queen side
and the knight is established on the d5
square so that would be good for black
therefore well why should actually do is
play the move Bishop takes d7 and here
the best is Queen takes e7 although
Bishop takes d7 is is also a fine move
playing for compensation Queen takes e7
Queen takes d7 Bishop takes d7 92 and
here the best move is rook to d8 I
keeping an eye on the d5 pawn d4 Bishop
to f5 Knight f4 g5 distracting the night
away from the d5 pawn 92 rook g8
protecting g5 Bishop e3 95 with a
slightly better position for black do
too as bishop pair and the better
structure so that means that the move
Bishop to b5 check is is not very
critical and best is probably the move
Knight to c3 actually there's there's
another move I should mention which is
Queen to a4 and it's kind of the same
all you need to do is you need to play
the move Knight to d7 and eventually the
idea let's say let's say Knight 993 you
can play something like a six the goal
is to play for b5
and I there there are a lot of there
there's not a lot white can do to to get
in perversion of the previous positions
so this is totally fine for black anyway
the best moves nice Knight to c3 Knight
takes d5 is my recommended move here
white will usually play Knight to Knight
to f3 other moves are either worse or
rule transposed to later lines 96 and
Bishop to b5 now there is this move
Bishop to c4 which is very sneaky
because what white would really like is
if black were to play something like e 6
and then Y it would go d4 because this
is a very decent version of the panel
white will get some attack and blacks
already committed to this movie 6
whereas Bishop won't be very good so
later why we'll have more attackers than
black hole defenders I don't I don't
like this position I'm not saying this
position is necessarily bad but it's
very unpleasant to play from the from
the black side so instead what we should
do is after Bishop c4 let's play the
move Knight to b6 the bishop she
returned to b3 and here it's important
to remember to play Bishop to f5 you
should not play the move Bishop to g4
why is Bishop to g4 a bad move pause
your video at home or use your computer
get a snack whatever you want to do this
is a very common trick in the Italian I
think
and then Cain takes up seven that's
correct yeah Bensimon no means yes in 95
and if the King moves anywhere then you
take on g4 and yeah what's just up upon
and clearly a better position black
can't castle this is close to winning so
that's why you should go Bishop f5
remember that this square is almost
always taboo if white has the ability to
play Bishop takes f7 and Knight to g5
with very few exceptions so here white
will play d4 and you should go a six and
this position is totally safe for black
play might continue castles or sorry
here instead of instead of d4 castles
should just transpose e 64 Bishop e7
white will go deep five to try to
equalize because if he doesn't play d5
then he's just clearly worse with his
isolated pawn d5 take take take take
take take castle and black is even
slightly better here because more of his
pieces are developed so that that line
shouldn't be a problem either so let's
move on to the main line of main lines
within this variation and that's Bishop
to b5 now a lot of people they like
playing moves like e6000
when I when I've faced this variation
because most of the time people play the
accelerated pan off because they want to
avoid the main line so they don't really
study the positions in a lot of depth
obviously white players are more
concerned with the Sicilian in like a 45
so they don't look at the Cairo that
often and also every time I've reached
the critical position which is okay
Queen a4 Knight to b6 it's very
important you remember this this move if
you play some other move here you might
lose so if you play Bishop to g7 white
to play what would you do with white
yeah take take the night and if I take
bow then you take back and what's the
problem yeah so if I play Queen to d7
then you win the rook and if I play
Bishop d7 my Rick's is defended by my
knight same so white just wins material
so Bishop g7 is very important to
remember the white is actually
threatening something here and what you
do is you play Knight to b6 and this is
a pawn sacrifice black plays sorry white
white has to take on c6 to justify
anything that he's done if he moves away
anywhere then you just move your bishop
out to g7 and you Castle and blacks
clearly better bishops e6 pawn takes
Queen takes Bishop to d7 Queen to e4
this is all fairly natural Bishop to g7
d4 so this is the second moment where
maybe the most natural move because
Bishop g7 was the most natural move in
the previous position it just lost
material the most natural move is not
the best move what would you all do here
with black just you know your knee-jerk
reaction it's not a trick question
yeah everybody here with Castle right it
just it just happens that castling here
is slightly inaccurate because when
white castles there's an there's no
Bishop to c6 so likewise kind of safe he
goes back you plays Bishop e3 and even
here blacks okay like I don't even
rather be black here but white is
objectively better so if you want full
equality then here I would recommend
playing the move rook to c8 and if white
castles now you have the move Bishop to
see to c6 the bishops getting on this
diagonal Queen to e2 and here we can
take on f3 and we can take on d4 and
black has totally equalized the material
is even and black will make up the time
and development although you still need
to be a little bit precise Bishop to e3
Queen to b4 so we're putting pressure on
the b2 pawn in this diagonal
and sorry that's that's that's basically
at the end of the line because like just
going to castle next move for white us
to deal with this threat if you play
something like brick b1 castles black is
already totally fine with with an even
position so hopefully that answered I
forget who who made the comment but that
person's question about the accelerator
pan off and let's move on to the main
meat of this video which is the advanced
variation so we'll start with the old
main lines
efore c6 d 4 D 5 D 5 this is of course
the starting position a use I I will
recommend recommend the move Bishop to
f5 that being said c5 is a very decent
alternative if I'll look at that in a
little bit but let's let's just work
I'll worry about Bishop f5 so Bishop f5
is the most solid solid move and
responds putting our Bishop on are the
best diagonal I'm getting ready to put
it outside of the pawn chain so just
like the a6 Slav and whatever you and
you would do against the ready with d5
c6 we get our Bishop outside the the
pawn chain and then we try to attack
White's white Center black is very solid
and it's really hard to to immediately
punish him but if white tries this is
what he'll do
Knight to c3 is the main move but here
some people like playing g4 chasing the
bishop around the move Bishop to d7 is
the main move I believe although I don't
think it's best Bishop d7 c4 e6 Knight
c3 and this position is very complicated
in double edge White's played the move
g4 which is bad but at the same time
White has space with c4 Knight c3 nice
gain time this position is unclear
probably around equal but the best move
for black is to play bishop g6 and if
white plays the movie 6 which is usually
the refutation
playing Bishop g6 against you for then
here black has a very strong move in in
Queen to d6 if you were to play F takes
c6 then II five is really weak so Knight
of 395 is strong don't do this this is
not something that you want but Queen to
d6 threatening Queen takes c6 check
sorry Bishop f7 I'm sorry ef7 Bishop f7
native 397 covering e5 Bishop d3 castles
Queen side and black is actually better
here why it hasn't developed none of his
Queen side pieces and if he castles King
side it's virtually suicide I mean look
at his pawn in g4 or opposite side
castles h5 g5 everything's coming out of
whites Kanan yeah black is clearly
clearly better so white would be advised
not to play this variation so g4 is a
bad move
what white should do is play the move
Knight to c3 if he wants to play g4 you
should go you six if white doesn't play
g4 the knight c3 is really silly because
blacks main idea in these structures
that being a French at caro-kann or
anything when when when you have this
pawn structure is to play the move c7 to
c5 in this case c6 to c5 and we want to
break down the pawn structure the way
that white would combat that or make
sure that his pawn structure doesn't
completely fall apart is by playing c2
to c3 which of course it's not possible
with a knight on c3 so the only thing
that white can do here is is is play g4
and play for time because if you if you
try to play for some structural thing or
anything like that then then blacks just
gonna be better something like Bishop e2
c5 and blacks already better so g5 sorry
g4 bishop g6 92 if white plays h4 then
this position is much better for black
after h5 you you you immediately capture
the pawn on g4 unless you plays f3 or
actually yeah sorry if f3 then we just
take and take and we win
but if you place g5 then we put our
knight on f5 or our Bishop on f5 and
support it with our Knight
this is positional suicide we play c5
next I mean this is a dream for any
Cairo player
so white will play Knight to e2 with the
point that he wants to put his knight on
f4 before playing the move HT to h4
because as I discussed in last last
week's election or yeah last week's
lecture maybe I don't know maybe was two
weeks ago I don't remember when when you
have this pawn structure and white plays
the move H to h4 in you're forced to
play h6 and give away your bishop for
this Knight this imaginary knight on f4
this is never a good structure you will
almost certainly lose everything else
being equal so I mean if you're up a
queen then you it's fine you can have
that pawn structure but in general you
don't you don't you don't want this so
white has a has a threat of playing
Knight f4 and h4 and blowing black off
the board there there there are a lot of
sidelines here f6 is a very decent move
actually because after Knight f4
strangely enough black can play F takes
e5 Knight G 6hg takes in 97 see the
difference is is that we're we've we've
given white a target on e5 Bishop R
sorry we've given ourselves a target to
attack right Bishop f4 Bishop b4 Bishop
d3 97 and black is fine this position
isn't better for better for black this
is like equal maybe White's even
slightly better because these pawns are
really bad but this is playable if you
don't want to play the main lines and
also White has to know this like White
has to know after 97 to play Bishop d3
here ok and I mean these moves are kind
of natural but it's something to
consider especially in blitz
but here the best move is to play
move c5 another side line which I played
for a long time was h5 and after night
to see Knight to f4 I would again there
there are two moves you can play H takes
g4 with the point that now that now that
the Queen's here we can start putting
our knight on f5 and this is an
interesting position but mm probably why
it's better
so what black should do is play Bishop
h7 and then if Knight takes h5 ok she
takes h5 it isn't like we're down upon
because they're double isolated eh pawns
and we put our knight on f5 so that's
obviously good for black so white will
take on a try with his Knight and here I
was playing the move to c5 with the
complicated position that's around equal
but if you want to be better and better
with black out of the opening which is
always nice then you should go c5 h4 h5
night of four and here Bishop h7 the
point is Knight takes is a and Knight
takes H 596 DC for Bishop c5 997 is
actually a terrible move because after
Tina Fey Black has all of his pieces
developed and is already attacking and
White's moved one night even the entire
game so Bishop to b5 Queen to c7 Bishop
c6 Queen c6 Queen f3 castles and black
is better so white shouldn't play like
this what white should there there are
alternatives to playing the short
variation one of the aggressive lines
the white likes to play is h4 which is
actually more more challenging than any
set up with g4 in my opinion and
probably the opinion of any modern
computer h5 c4 and it's strange right
you go h4 and then you play C 4 but
White's point is now that blacks
committed to the move h5 and H 5 is by
no means force but it's kind of
unpleasant to play this position
if like this this version might might
might be worse because if you go to g6
then after f7 Queen d6 take on f7 with
check we're not taking back with the
bishop and the King would have to be on
f7 as opposed to ca so that would be
unadvisable but h5 prevents g4 full stop
white will almost always play c4 this is
a very positional line I believe there's
a side line here oops there's a side
line here with Bishop to g5 but if black
knows what he's doing he's fine this is
very dangerous if you don't know what
you're doing if you play some random
move like 97 weight gets white gets a
huge attack it's like Bishop d3 and e6
coming but Queen to b6 Bishop to d3
Queen takes d4 is the best the point is
that if if black I sorry if white plays
Bishop takes f5 then we have Queen takes
e5 which is a fork Knight to f3 Queen to
g4 and this this position is better for
black I believe there's a game let's
there's a game between filly poof and a
solid
so here see for this is the best movie
692 c3 ninety seven ninety two ninety
seven ninety three the ship g6 now I
played a game against auction Andhra I
believe in the st. Loup and some st.
Louis bliss tournament and he played the
move how this go it was it was like
Bishop to e2 and takes no no take take
take
aha yeah he took on d5 I took on d5 and
he played Bishop e2 and here it's
important to note that why it's not
actually threatening a pawn because if
if white were to take on h5 like let's
say takes takes and white takes on h5
right with or sorry like pass move seems
like a good move if white takes on h5
then I said like a six if white takes on
h5 then we can actually take on e5 and
if they take on e5 then we take on d1
and take on h5 and black is better this
is a cool trick to remember so white
white actually in a lot of positions I
don't know if this is what the exact
variation but if white plays something
like Bishop e2 and and gains up on the
h5 pawn then black has this trick of
removing the guard with a Knight takes
e5 and Queen takes d1 and you wins this
pawn back with a superior position so
that's not really serious night-night g2
is played to go to g3 and then Bishop g5
Queen b6 Queen d2 take take Queen b3
isn't serious because every ending is
good for black so 22 takes takes castles
98 for Queen c7 Brooksie one night
Knight takes e5 Bishop to f4
there are a lot of variations here
okay the reason why we put our queen MC
sound is obviously there are no there's
no better Square rook to c1 lines the
rook up on the same file as the Queen
Knight takes e5 I mean black black
doesn't need to grab some material in
order to just justify his play I mean if
White's just a lot to remain this active
with you even material then white will
be better so bishops have four and here
Knights Knight takes e4 is the is the
tactic Bishop see 792 Bishop da Knight
to e4 Bishop e7 Bishop e7 and the
position is roughly balanced White has
an exchange but black has the two
bishops and I believe a pawn for the
exchange in White's pawn on d4 is
isolated black has a perfect structure
I'm sorry black has two pawns but you
know white has open lines for his rooks
so I would rather be black but I think
objectively this is equal
I think that does it for for all of the
kill variations of the advance any
questions so far
and everything clear or okay alright so
now now we get to the real challenging
stuff and this legitimately might refute
the opening and so you have to be very
very precise with with everything that
you do and this is the short the short
variation oh sorry actually before
before we get into that I I mentioned
that c5 is a possible alternative so you
everything I just said could be moved
but my issue with this is I believe
white gets a good position after a
bishop beef even even the sidelines here
with c4 do I have yeah c4 takes Knight
f3 Bishop c4 takes Queen takes Knight c3
takes takes or this is even a bad
version but if if black if this ever
happens on the board black is just
clearly clearly worse so even this side
line is dangerous with Knight of 3 and C
4 and also the main line with DC 5 I am
not entirely sure black equalizes he
might the line continued something like
this with interesting play White's
probably slightly better but Black has
two bishops and very decent practical
chances
so that's an alternative if you don't
like Bishop f5 but Bishop f5 Knight f3
is the short variation but there's
another move here instead of playing h4
h5 c4 there's the immediate c4 e6
9c 397 a3 it's funny people play a3 a
lot in these variations because they're
afraid of some Bishop arriving on b4 and
just totally crushing white and also
it's it's not really clear what what
useful thing I can do and you want to
play c5 and B before like this is the
most useful thing that I can do at this
time takes takes Knight to d7 92 96 but
should be 395 and it's very easy to play
black all you have to do is play Bishop
d7 you Castle kingside you you triple on
the D file I don't know how it's
possible but you somehow do it and then
you take d4 like this is your target
this is what you want to take and if you
play Knight 63 then d4 won't be your
target anymore instead c3 will be your
target so then you'll play like 95 Queen
I five blacks plan is very easy and this
position is roughly balanced very decent
play for both sides the better player
will win so finally we arrive to the
main line main line of main lines here
ISA 'kx Bishop to e2 c5 is is my
proposed move although I will mention
some possible alternatives now these the
this is the move that I've played in
practice the most which is 97 castles h6
Knight 1992 is the main line if y does
something else then I'm not even sure
what else like if you play Bishop e3
then we'll go c5 or something so or no
that's terrible what am I talking about
if Bishop e3 we just go ninety seven is
the same except white doesn't get his
clamp on c5 so 97 anyway 92
ninety-seven Knight b3 this is the point
of whites play white is clamping down on
c5 and now he can play Bishop III and he
won't disturb his knight the next move
and black goes g5 in my opinion this
position is objectively a draw quotation
marks I think if you look at any
correspondence database and you look at
the computer it'll say like zeros and
you know every games a draw like this is
the database right like the draw rate is
sixty one percent for ninety one fit in
yeah just it's either draw or black has
has a positive score however I do
believe this is very very difficult to
play in practice it's not easy to play
g5 the main line goes ninety one Quincy
seven ninety three so White's continuing
his grip on c5 b6 Bishop e3 Bishop g7
and white goes off four and here already
you should be able to see some of the
potential problems you're ultimately
computer off with with blacks position
it's objectively fine but it's really
hard to play this type of position where
your entire King site is ruined and okay
these moves these moves are played in
the in position black will have to
Center pawns to whites none so that's as
compensation for having the worst King
safety ever if you want to play that and
play this you know empowered to you this
is not something that I would be willing
to recommend though because I feel like
in practice white will white white will
below the 2700 level white will win the
majority of the games so sorry
instead of that there's another
alternative which is a knight to e7 and
I never like doing this 97 castles 97
because if if white so chooses you can
play the move Knight to h4 and this type
of position like let's save the ship g6
I don't know if the immediate capture
some later capture this type of position
is very easy to play for white you play
c3 f/4g for kingi - you put your knight
on f3 you put your bishop on e3 you're
playing as h4 h5 like and okay black's
going like c5 and stuff this is also
very solid I have a friend named Steve
wine he likes to play this with black a
lot but the reason why Steve wins all
his games because he's good at chess not
because this position is good so helps
when you're 2400 USCF anyway I don't I
don't think that this is this is a good
position and you should you should stay
away from this although it's certainly
easier to play and I feel like below the
tool the below in like 2,500 people
should have no difficulty I mean it
probably the scores are even I think
above that white will score more than
black but you know if you're 2500 you're
not listening to my videos so anyway who
knows castles I'm sorry the other side
line is Knight to e7 castles c5 this is
also very decent
I do believe white is slightly better
although it's practically a lot easier
to play and I think it doesn't matter
what level you are like unless you're a
computer you you won't be able to get an
advantage with white the best move is c4
Knight BC 693 a 6 d c5 d for Queen to a
496 we're attacking the 5 pawn we won
again again that rook to d1 now if we
take on e5 twice then D force hanging so
Bishop takes c5 before Bishop to a7 c5
and white should be better here
yeah this position has never been to my
tastes because white has more space
white it seems like White's plane is
really easy you just play on the
kingside you eventually round up the d4
pawn and you stand better the bishop on
a7 isn't very good but at the same time
black is really solid you're not going
to get mated your plan is to attack the
e5 point play plays very interesting
once again I believe the better player
will win this is not what I what I will
recommend another another side line you
have to kind of mix it up actually like
it's best if you play every single line
I think from my personal experience
against short players because they you
know they study a lot of theory in the
main lines and you have to keep them
guessing if and if they're preparing for
you and they see that you play the same
thing every game then maybe they will
actually like surprise you but if you
kind of play a little bit of everything
and you just have you know the the
general understanding of the position
then then you'll be fine but the side
line that I like the most the one that's
the least common is c5 Bishop e3 and
this is actually my recommendation so
far but okay what I recommend here is to
play C takes d4 but my side line is the
move Queen to b6 now unfortunately after
Knight to c3 Queen takes b2 is in a very
good move
it's weird why actually can win a rook
here but or he can trade Queens which
would you rather do audience win or rook
or trade Queens this is a trick question
right and I never do that never do that
and chess rooks are the most worthless
things ever you know okay obviously Y
can go here in play nice e7 and the best
move is you just play c4 and it doesn't
matter because after 97 qd7
we play the move Bishop c2 and after
Queen see one Bishop a3 black actually
is as is better in pushing
but it's it's funny I actually really
like that like if you win a rook you're
worse but here trading Queens and whites
significantly better this is not a fun
position to play with black you're so
far behind in development it just
doesn't matter that the Queen's are
coming off the board there is a trick
why can't black play Queen takes c3
check pause your videos at home if you
don't know there's a famous I believe
Christensen Sarah won game starting in
this position all the way I don't
remember Yassir play Queen takes c3 no I
think you play Queen c2 and got crushed
Queen takes c3 good move
I mean free night right who doesn't like
free nights okay I'll put the position
well you're in check so how do you deal
with this problem yeah so Bishop d2 is
the most obvious move and correct and
let's say black just takes on c2 what
would you do here would you just say oh
well I'm down on everything cry take the
Queen if you take the Queen Bishop takes
and then Black has actually winning
winning
real winning not my pretend winning in
all these videos but winning hand if you
Castle black will trick queens you can't
do that like you need to prove something
now if you don't do something now than
you lose luckily for you there's
something of black blacks that's trapped
I'll give you a hint it is not the Queen
tonight eh [ __ ] still couldn't be
wondering you need to move your queen
alright
Bishop Bishop where do you want but
still the problem is that there's Queen
Queen doing my hint is that it's not the
Queen so you shouldn't be trying to
attack the Queen and you shouldn't be
trying to attack the bishop because
they're protected by everything but
there is something about yes there here
we go
Queen be seven and the rook is trapped
and black loses all of his pieces and
it's really sad too because not only do
you lose your rook on a eight but your
knight is probably soon to follow
anyway so you don't do that but Queen
takes me one's a bad ending for for
black but here I like this move pawn to
c4 and this this actually comes from a
combination of two openings this isn't
very common I think it's been played in
the database well actually you Wow
well this has happened a lot recently
this must be new
you have 2017 I I am a little outdated
but there are 21 games in the database
it's still not like the most common but
when when I was playing it there were
like two games in the database and one
of those games was mine so yeah so c4
this comes from the idea comes from the
French one or actually so if we go back
then you go e six d4 d5 Knight c3 Bishop
to b4 b5 my favorite variation of the
French winnow R is this one with Queen
to a5 Bishop to d2 and playing the move
Queen to a4 and the point is if white
goes Queen to b1 we place c4 and it's
it's a really tense struggle where
blacks like playing and playing on the
Queen side and White's trying to get
mate this is a complicated position not
not for this not for this lecture but
anyway so here after after the move c5
Bishop e3 Queen b6 Knight c3 I like the
move c4 with the idea that after rook to
b1 which is practically forced the other
move is b3 which gives white and no
advantage after b3 Bishop b4 there's 52
Queen a 599 a 497 Bishop before Queen
before c3 Queen I five black is totally
fine the bishop on it on a5
quote-unquote blacks bad Bishop is
controlling this entire diagonal
preventing repeat one for the entire
game Quincy 197 this is just possible
play Knight B to be 5 and black is
probably I would rather be black here
instead white white should play rook to
be one Bishop b4 castles Bishop c3
Bishop c3 Queen to a6 and this is very
similar to the last position because I
mean the pawn structure is virtually the
same right White has these double pawns
all the pieces are the same too it's
just where the pieces are located is
kind of different
I would argue this is an improved
version right although maybe that's not
true maybe this position slightly
dubious but ok the bishops on f5 so it's
outside of the pawn chain that's a claim
that you could make for an improvement
we could also claim the Queen on a6 is
is putting pressure on a 2 is not
necessarily held to the a Foursquare
although if white plays the move rook a1
to play four then we can certainly play
Queen I forward to stop that this is a
very interesting position and if you
play this certainly below the man the
2600 level which is like everybody right
like nobody's 2600 then you're going to
have very none of your opponents will
know those position with with the white
pieces this will never be studied I
played at 2200 and he like blundered
upon immediately like in this position
he didn't grant it I didn't win the game
but that's mostly due to you know my
stupidity rather than uh anything else
but after c4 he played castles and just
blundered his pawn on b2 because he
forgot that now now now that the pawns
on c4 none of the same place still
really exists so yeah rook b1 Bishop
before take take Quinn a six-night h4
Bishop to g6 f4 97g for Bishop to g4 Oh
whites 13 f5 to trap your bishop so you
play Bishop b4 f 596
f6g takes rook takes and this is really
the start of all of the nonsense and I
hope everybody has fun analyzing this
position I this is my second favorite
line of the of the Cairo and if you if
you need to play for a win I would
recommend this one as opposed to my main
recommendation which is basically trying
to make a draw because well white is
better in this line so I recommend C
takes d4 Knight takes d4 97 c4 Knight
night bc6 Queen I force the main line
here you should play a six white will
play Knight e3 we want to simplify it
the reason why we play 97 it's never a
good idea to take on a5 and just let
black take back on a5 because blacks and
I don't f5 is amazing and you your
White's gonna lose time by moving his
Bishop on e3 and if he doesn't lose time
then white doesn't even have the bishop
pair so C 496 Queen I for a six so we're
threatening we're threatening to play D
takes e4 and B 593 kind of prevents that
because if these DC 4 then actually
there's there's some sorry I I'm gonna
shoot for a second this this position
Knight c4 just wins because there's 96
so yeah 97 i p5 takes takes here and
after the Queen goes then we play Knight
Knight to d6 and this position is much
better for white and by much better I
mean winning anyway so
so you don't do that you play Queen f5
to trade Queens white castles take on c4
you play Bishop to e4 black has
simplified the position dramatically the
bishop should return to e2 well white
shouldn't allow black to establish a
knight on d5 forever so Bishop to e2 now
white when he has a space advantage
doesn't want to trade pieces so every
trade that we make is more advantageous
for us actually if we go to a kingdom
planet name probably blacks winning just
stone cold winning so white really needs
to be careful which way with which
pieces he's actually trading rook c8 or
XC and I see a cape rook c1 and here the
move Queen to d7 and as far as anybody's
concerned this positions totally equal
it's very easy to play black you just
play Bishop e7 next unless white plays
work doom on the new and you play 97 but
whatever this position if you get here
then you should be fine with black so I
have more analysis in the study let's
let's move on to slightly more critical
and critical lines after 97 c4 Knight b
c6 slang go again Knight if I was always
bad C 93 25 that isn't right I think it
was oh yeah
so here if white castles you should go
Knight b c6
if Bishop to b5 a6 Bishop c6 b c6 c4
Queen d7 and blacks actually already
already fighting or sorry yeah Queen d7
9c3
on c4 Knight to a4 95 stopping Knight b6
takes takes rook c1 c3 93-63 takes g6e
for Queen d1 takes Bishop g7 and this
position is is equal although it's not
it's not even equal where you have to
immediately accept a draw like there's a
whole bunch of imbalances here the
better player will win although maybe
this is slightly easier to play for for
white
but I think a sense subjectively its its
equal and you know since it's already an
ending it's really hard to blunder all
your pieces the other there was another
line here see I can there's a lot of a
lot of theory so yeah
92 96 negative 3 Bishop to e4 castles so
the reason why white plays Knight d2 is
he wants to establish establish a firm
grip on the center with something like
f4 Knight f3
so why needs to act pretty immediately
so you play knight c6 now if white does
something silly like f4 you take on d4
and play knight c6 and blacks already
better
so now white plays Knight Knight to f3
defending e5 defending d4 black plays
Bishop before all the Bishop g4 is also
possible castles 96 takes takes Knight
g5 Bishop d7 takes takes Queen to d4
Queen d5 Queen at c3 castles rook d1 and
this is the the thing that you're going
to have to remember when you get to this
position and positions like this it's
very important to remember that the
bishop money to is hanging and the Queen
on c3 is connected to the keen on g1 so
Knight f4 is a very nice move because if
you don't have night 1/4 and everything
I just said it was all nonsense but you
do have an IG 4 and after Bishop f1 you
can defend your g7 pawn with the Queen
to g5 so if you ever get to this
position it's very important you
remember night of 4 or you find it which
you should be able to because you know
if you do tactics this is this is a very
common theme bishop f1 Queen g5 Queen c6
Bishop f6 g3 Knight goes to d5 c-4
Bishop 64 and Knight goes to f6
this is possible play already black is
equalized after Queen b5
you shouldn't trade Queens c5 rook e1 h6
protecting the Queen's
we were threatening d4 Brooke after h4
queen of five the position is is
balanced although I would prefer playing
black because you could get some kind of
inside initiative I'm not sure how
serious whites play on the on the Queen
side is immediately it is very it is
very clear that white has long-term
advantages but I don't think that um I
don't think that that he's gonna have
time to time to just push his Queen
cyclones so that that line that line
equalizes yes any questions about
anything I just said you notes yes yes
this is all from the advanced variation
yeah it it is the most common at
Grandmaster proc practice and even even
amateur games because I mean if you're
not careful
I mean I've showed all the lines that
equalized for black but I could just as
easily show all the lines Porsche
I mean if black doesn't do that man
Amanda's black it crush and if you're if
you're a Carroll player and you've
played anybody anybody above 2500 feet a
you know you know that it's just
absolutely pain to play to play these
positions against against the
Grandmaster you have to remember all
this theory and if you don't I recommend
a whole bunch of sidelines where you
don't need to know as much theory right
you could just kind of play and that's
against like lower rated players but if
you play that against somebody better
then probably your results won't be as
good so anyway if if I forgot to if I
forgot to mention a line I apologize
thank you all very much
this was part part two of part two of
the never never and ending series by
Julian Polly good bye
[Music]